in this problem two basins of the same
size shape and slope are being analyzed
using the Rational method the First
Basin is heavily wooded and the second
is heavily
urbanized assume all runoff from each
Basin runs to the same point in each
Basin with no storm water control
structures added to either Basin which
of the following statements is true the
First Basin will have a lower runoff
coefficient and a lower time of
concentration than the second Basin the
First Basin will have a lower runoff
coefficient and a higher time of
concentration than the second
Basin the First Basin will have a higher
runoff coefficient and a lower time of
concentration than the second
Basin the First Basin will have a higher
runoff coefficient and a higher time of
concentration than the second
Basin so essentially we've got two
drainage areas
one heavily wooded and these are all the
pretty trees inside of
it second one is heavily urbanized and
here are all the
buildings on
it and they've noted in the problem that
pretty much everything else is the same
so they load to the same points at the
end and there's no like additional
engineering structures to control the
storm water so this is a question pretty
much just about the rational method
itself
um so page
406 that got cut
off or PDF
page
48 will give you the rational method if
you want to look at it it's pretty much
just going to show you that
volume equals I *
area time C *
T which is going to
be I is the intensity of
rainfall C is the rational method runoff
coefficient which is called out in the
problem a is the drainage area and then
T is going to be the time or in this
case the time of
concentration
[Music]
so area is not going to change between
these two and the average rainfall
intensity is a non-factor for the
problem so really this is just a
question about the two other parameters
here
so if you want you can also look at page
for a table of runoff
coefficients this would actually be
helpful since the question is asking
about whether or not each Basin will
have a lower or higher runoff
coefficient but the point of the problem
is pretty much just to determine whether
or not you understand runoff
coefficients and Times of con
concentration as they apply to the real
world so since the First Basin is
heavily wooded let's start by going to
that table of runoff
coefficients and if we look for
unimproved areas we can see that the
runoff coefficient is between 0.1 and.
3 and then all of the urban ized areas
seem to have a runoff coefficient value
that's higher than
that a heavily wooded area would be an
example of an unimproved area so that's
sort of something you have to know but
you could also infer it from the other
more nature Centric runoff coefficients
at the table so this is going to show us
that the runoff coefficient for a for
the First Basin is going to be lower so
that's immediately going to give us
either
this one or this
one and now we have to ask about the
time of
concentration so the time of
concentration is going to be based on
the speed at which it takes all of the
flow in the drainage
area the flow from the farthest point to
start contributing to the flow at the
outlet where it's being
measured so in a heavily wooded area the
water is going to move a lot slower
through it than in a heavily urbanized
area where the water is going to run off
not infiltrate at all and generally move
at a higher velocity with way less lag
time so this problem is as
straightforward as that where we can see
that the First Basin is going to have a
lower runoff coefficient and a higher
time of
concentration than would an identical
second Basin that is much more urbanized
so that's really all it takes to solve
this problem